we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p as many of you know we have
had a couple of segments this week
pointing out the troubles that we are
experiencing thanks to what's happening
on youtube recently and i got some nice
words of encouragement just a very
positive message this is inspirational
and flattering in many ways very
different by the way than most of the
voicemails and emails that I receive
take a listen hey David my name is AJ
from California I saw your video in
regards to what YouTube is doing to your
channel and a myriad of others I just
wanted to give a little bit of an
encouraging message to tell you not to
give up you have a substantial amount of
followers that really like and respect
what you're doing and for me personally
not only are you my favorite political
commentator but you were the big
motivation that I needed to actually
start my own channel and I reference you
not just as resources to friends of mine
that I know locally but also
consistently well on the channel as well
so please fight that good fight you're
going to have a lot of support here and
I guarantee you also from a ton of
others if I had the monetary mean to
support you on patreon i 100% would but
I have gotten a couple of people that I
know to do so thank you and I'm doing
that vicariously through them so hope
you have a great rest day and I hope
this message finds you well
thank you beautiful beautiful message
very much appreciate it we are doing
everything we can to replace all lost
YouTube revenue thanks to a couple of
hundred people in the last couple of
days who have added their financial
support we made up a piece of it we made
up a piece of it over the last few days
and it's been inspiring and heartwarming
to see the degree to which there have
been new supporters coming into the fray
thanks to everybody and we will talk to
you on the bonus show where all of these
new supporters will be able to join us
we'll be talking about turmoil at the
NRA with their TV channel ending great
news we will talk about the health
effects of drinking really cold water
there's a couple interesting studies and
I have a funny family anecdote about
that and much more join the membership
program or patreon to get instant access
to the bonus show